hola a todos una gran pregunta hace
cuánto le tomaste la llamada a tu
propósito de vida hace una semana hace
un mes
hace un año hace una década no sabes
incluso cuál es tu propósito de vida
esta pregunta yo no sabía lo que era el
propósito pero tenía las señales que me
movería a lo que hoy es mi propósito
desde muy pequeña sabía que me
inquietaba el dolor ajeno' la inequidad
la injusticia sabía que tenía una
vocación social que tenía aptitudes
emprendedoras y sabía que quería y podía
hacer la diferencia hoy después de
muchos años puedo reducir y resumir mi
propósito de vida en tres palabras
servir crear y conectar por supuesto que
no es un proceso fácil es un proceso
introspección de muchos años pero justo
hoy les quiero compartir eso que
significó para mí llegar a este viaje y
cuáles fueron las llamadas que contesté
y aquellas que no contesté para estar
aquí voy para saber hacia dónde voy y
sobre todo rectificar
camino cuando voy por el camino
equivocado y para eso voy a transportar
al 2007 tenía 27 años y si yo me pudiera
ver en un espejo así me vería con una
mujer que lo podía todo que pueda
conquistar el mundo que ya era
independiente que tenía grandes retos
personales y profesionales que me
entusiasman mucho que podía lidiar con
no dormir con no comer con tener buenas
y malas relaciones
un día una mañana estando mi papá
visitándome en en la casa
me dejó en la mesa del desayuno una
servilleta al lado de la caja de cereal
y cuando la leo me encontré con esto
lo que llamo yo la servilleta reveladora
y en una servilleta mi papá me puso esta
nota flors si no cambias de dirección
llegarás al punto exacto al que te
diriges te quiero papá
no tenía ni idea de que quería decir mi
papá con esta nota
pero dándole vueltas y vueltas y vueltas
después de verme yo en este espejo me di
cuenta que probablemente lo que él veía
hay muchas otras personas veían era esto
una mujer acelerada desaforada viviendo
demasiado rápido por un propósito
que probablemente no me llevaría hacia
donde yo quería que probablemente me
llevaría hacia el precipicio y no porque
porque estuviera haciendo otra cosa que
no supiera hacer o que no me apasiona
hacer heredé de mi mamá la disciplina el
humanismo y de mi papá la generosidad
desde muy pequeña yo sabía que yo quería
ayudar a los demás sentía que quería
cambiar al mundo y que algo podría hacer
para que eso sucediera pero lo que
sentía es que estaba en un marco
desbordado y en un marco de referencia
equivocado
sabía que quería servir y no servirme
sabía que la vida era una carrera pero
yo estaba jugando carreritas
sabía que una relación inquebrantable
entre ser fiel al mundo y ser fiel a uno
mismo
pero lo que no estaba consciente en ese
llamado en ese momento y que fue la
llamada que marcó de una manera muy
importante mi vida fue que no me estaba
contestando a mí misma estaba siendo
fiel al mundo pero no estaba siendo
sustentable conmigo no iba hacia el
camino al que yo quería ir
y entonces me topé con esta frase de
ortega y gasset que dice a dónde vas con
tanta prisa si es a ti mismo a quien
debes llegar y es ahí donde el proceso
introspección se hizo mucho mucho más
profundo y me transporté años atrás
incluso y comencé a recordar mis
llamadas esas llamadas que tuve en la
infancia mis primeros veinte de mis
veinte a mis treinta y ahorita en la
década de 1.030 mis cuarenta que
significaba que momentos tenía
recordaba cómo de pequeño organicé con
mis hermanos una venta de garaje y
sacamos toda la despensa para vender
todo y regalar casi todo más bien a los
albañiles que estaban construyendo casas
cercanas a donde vivíamos recordé
también que todas las navidades mis
papás nos pedían que guardáramos ropa y
juguetes para regalar a los niños a las
familias en matehuala en la carretera
cuando nos íbamos a visitar a la familia
y recuerdo muy bien como una señora en
una de esas paradas en matehuala siendo
que mi mamá cargaba mi hermana más
pequeña
y la otra señora tenía una bebé cargada
de la misma edad
mi mamá percibió que la niña se le quedó
viendo a los guardaditos de mi hermana y
en ese instante yo tenía 8 años mi
hermana tenía uno en ese instante y mi
mamá le quitó el zapato a mi hermana
para dárselo a esa señora sin decir nada
recuerde que ese momento me había
marcado y que no lo platiqué con mi mamá
hasta 30 años después recordé que en mis
años en los veintes me involucré en
grupos estudiantiles y tuve la gran
fortuna de participar en congresos
internacionales de haber sido asistente
particular de kofi annan de conocer en
persona y platicar con fidel castro pero
lo que representaba no era el lo que hay
en lo que podría hacer para muchos
valioso el exponer algo que podría ser
presumible lo más valioso es que yo
estaba ganando confianza en mí misma
estaba ganando esa libertad la libertad
de poderme transportar al futuro
repensar las cosas con crear el presente
y visualizar un futuro mucho mejor de
ser creativa la oportunidad de poder
tener una idea y esperar a otros para
que se que se sumarán a ella no
y organizar movimientos organizar
proyectos recaudar fondos
con una sola cosa pasión
en mis años 30 recordé que tenía una
cosa que para mí era muy importante
tener una familia y una persona con
quien compartir mi proyecto de vida hoy
tengo tres hijos maravillosos y un
esposo que complementa mucho mi vida
pero que ha sido parte de este propósito
que he buscado orientar mi vida y
reconocer mi propio inventario y cuando
reconoces tu propia mentar ya lo que te
encuentras es en esa magia que te dan
los poderes de saber que puedes ser
parte de las soluciones que puedes crear
cosas que está en ti responderle al
mundo y lograr lo que tú quieres
y que no está en quejarnos de los
gobernantes que tenemos que son tan
corruptos o de las las los bancos que
están generando deuda en los países en
desarrollo o de las comunidades que
estamos tirando el tejido social que
está bastante mal sino como nos
involucramos nosotros en los problemas y
reconocer el inventario que yo tenía a
mí me llevó a justamente tomar ese poder
para decidir sentarme con los
gobernantes sentarme con las comunidades
con crear proyectos y entender que lo
que yo quisiera hacer valía mucho más la
pena haciendo haciéndolo de manera
colaborativa hoy este propósito resumir
en las tres palabras que les compartí a
servir crear y conectar forman parte de
mi autopista con tres carriles hoy ya sé
que de eso no me salgo que por más
tentaciones y por más apasionada e
intensa que sea mientras esté en esos
carriles voy en el carril correcto o en
el camino correcto
recordé después de esta historia
es una historia apócrifa de un señor que
está sentado en el titanic imagínense en
el titanic buscando el mejor lugar la
mejor vista hacia el mar en el deck de
este barco
y las reflexiones
estar sentado en el mejor lugar de un
barco hundiéndose
es similar estar buscando el éxito
convencional en un mundo que parece
estarse haciendo pedazos
hoy
el tiempo de autoayuda el tiempo de
pensar en ti mismo y en tu éxito
convencional no es suficiente es el
momento de salir a las lanchas de salir
a los botes y de salvarnos todos es el
momento de colaborar es el momento de
cada uno de nosotros y esto me llevo a
cinco recordatorios
uno que llegamos a la meta cuando
llegamos todos
2 que si algo tienen las crisis globales
ahorita es que nos están dando el regalo
de entender que todos estamos
interconectados que la felicidad del
mundo depende de la felicidad de uno
mismo y que mi felicidad depende de la
felicidad del mundo y que las decisiones
que tomamos alrededor de esto todos los
días van marcando el rumbo de nosotros y
del mundo
al final es que le importas al mundo y
el mundo te importa a ti
otro de los recordatorios en los que han
marcado este propósito de vida es que se
vale celebrar las inconsistencias y aquí
le voy a hacer una pregunta
y esa luz también me ha pasado muchísimo
que me dicen oye lores y eres tan social
porque no tienes un carro híbrido porque
no limpia su casa con con puros
productos biodegradables porque trabajas
y tienes tres hijos menores de cinco
años por qué por qué por qué como sí
las cosas buenas que haces no fueron
suficiente si te tuvieras que martirizar
por tus valores como si tuviera que
hacer un monje o un villano y no hay una
cosa en medio y lo que descubrí que
también me da mucha tranquilidad es que
se vale vivir con estas inconsistencias
y celebrarlas por una simple razón
porque vale más ser inconsistente
teniendo un proyecto que integra tu
relación con el mundo
que ser consistente con tu egocentrismo
también como uno de mis recordatorios
recordé que vale la pena siempre tener
presente el gran premio de tu vida
cuáles son aquellas cosas que por ellas
morirías dónde está tu corazón dónde
están tus pasiones cómo mantienes este
equilibrio entre el mundo entre ti mismo
te lo sientes siempre presente y eso
para mí ha sido un recordatorio brutal
porque viéndolo como si fueran las bolas
de cristal para mí son aquellas que si
se rompen que si se caen al piso y se
rompen se me cae la vida entera mi
familia mis mejores amigos y el servir
aquí hay una historia que me gusta mucho
y que se las quiero compartir es la
historia de dos ranas que caen en un
bowl lleno de crema entonces imagínense
las ranas los bordes están altos no
pueden saltar no tienen como pegarse a
la pared y entonces una de ellas se
empiezan a dar y la otra se lee cada
bien 9 así con qué tonta ranas como como
cree que nadando a salir de aquí porque
estamos metidos en un bowl no vamos a
salir a ningún lado y la otra sigue nada
ni nada ni nada entonces la rana
inteligente
después de estar observando dicen esto
no nos va a llevar a ningún lado y
decidí ahogarse
groupe ya desapareció la rana
inteligente
la rana tonta sigue nadando nadando
nadando nadando hasta que de pronto se
encuentra parada sobre algo sólido
el siguiente paso brinca su primer paso
para nadar su segundo gran brinco su
segundo paso brincar llegó como arte de
magia y lo que sucedió no es es que con
esta analogía dígase nada para que
cambies el mundo y que tú tengas una
vida increíble la reflexión es de qué
tipo de persona quiere ser de qué tipo
de rana quiere ser la rana inteligente
que va a tener siempre pensando cuáles
son las limitaciones con las que te
estás enfrentando en el día a día o
quiere ser esa rana tonta que lo intenta
y lo intenta y que sigue su corazón
hasta que llegues hasta donde tú quieras
hoy mi invitación a ustedes es
comencé la llamada esa llamada que
ustedes saben que tienen pendiente
y que cuando sientan mucho ruido
alrededor le pongan al mundo externo y
se encuentren desde adentro
porque bien decía la poeta americana al
sexto para encontrar tu propósito sólo
basta pegar tu oído a tu alma y
escucharte muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]